it is then of course a day
for reflection it is a day
to take stock it is a day to lay oneself
on the table and make an assessment to
scrutinize one's decision making to
prioritize what's truly important to
re-center what is misaligned there is a
kind of
manic disquiet a kind of existential
angst that starts to creep in that
forces a response that tells us we must
be decisive we must take action a
decision must be made a change is due
friends isn't that what the new year is
about but shouldn't that be what every
day is about we spend so much of our
time making excuses we spend so much of
our time waiting for the right time and
instead friends this exorcism of our
neuroticism is is vital for our
transformation we must shake the snow
globe and cast away the south we must
hurl ourselves into the abyss we must
practice practice death practices we
must
hang ourselves on the cross in the sense
of stepping outside our comfort zone we
must make the difficult decision we must
take the road less traveled by we must
listen to our intuition we must make
silence for our inner voice and take
action in response so
the challenge friends becomes for all of
us will we do so
will we make the decision will we be
decisive in our actions
for the alternative we know what it is
is unconsciousness the default setting
the rat race
the constant gnawing sense of having had
and lost some infinite thing
having had and lost some infinite thing
nothing worse
than regret
friends
now friends the only way to answer the
disquiet is to take the journey the
journey itself is the medicine the world
in motion is the medicine it makes us an
observer it compels us into aesthetic
contemplation it forces us to encounter
things with that are commensurate to our
capacity for wonder and this is what we
need
and this friends is what we need so
answer the call take the journey
heed the disquiet
and make us all proud
let us hold ourselves accountable
let us make this the day the year the
moment the month the minute
let us begin